all right let's start today by going
through a few things about this week
that I didn't have time for earlier in
the week there's this guy named Charlie
Kirk he's part of the right wing group
Turning Point USA and he had a really
bad day on Tuesday Not only was Donald
Trump indicted but we saw Brendan
Johnson win the Mayoral race in Chicago
we also saw this liberal Supreme Court
Wisconsin Supreme Court candidate win
her race in Wisconsin making Wisconsin
now have a left-leaning supreme court
for the first time in 15 years and
Charlie Kirk recognizes that result
decreases their chances of being able to
win the White House in 24. he won't say
why but obviously it's because they plan
to cheat they plan to go to the Supreme
Court of Wisconsin to try to get the
Wisconsin electoral votes in 2024
whether or not their candidate gets the
most votes take a listen to this
yesterday was not a good day
Not only was Trump arraigned Wisconsin
was a blowout and there goes the
Wisconsin Supreme Court and it decreases
our chance to be able to win the White
House in 2024. it's not impossible but
we tried to warn people turning point
actions on the ground we were not going
to endures trying to raise money the RNC
nowhere to be found M.I.A that's why we
tried to do everything we could to get
regime change done at the RNC they
wouldn't be bothered they were too busy
doing their things that they do which is
nothing but pay themselves and
take care of their DC consultants and
then Chicago not as if it
was in a going in a hopeful Direction
decided to elect an outright Marxist
Marxist is going to become mayor of
Chicago okay he's not a Marxist but
let's focus in on the Supreme Court
piece of this the only way they can win
is cheating and overturning the will of
the voters he sang The Quiet part out
loud he is saying now now I'll give you
hit I know he doesn't mean to be saying
this but what he is in practice saying
is the way we were going to win in 2024
was by filing motions that would
hopefully get to the Wisconsin Supreme
Court and the Wisconsin Supreme Court
would decide to give us the electoral
votes now if you ask Charlie about it
he'll say no no no no I'm not saying
we're going to cheat what I mean is
Democrats will try to cheat
and then we will have to go to the
Supreme Court of Wisconsin in order to
get the rightful results which are that
Trump or whoever will be the winner but
who has a history of doing this stuff
remember you look at 2020. they spent
the entire summer saying Democrats are
going to try to cheat and we know they
actually tried to we know that they had
a number of these fraudulent elector
scams going in different states we know
that they filed endless motions to try
to circumvent the actual will of the
people
uh this is actually very good news for
Wisconsin where in Wisconsin you have
women worried about losing control over
their own medical care who now have a
better shot at retaining it thanks to
the change in the Wisconsin Supreme
Court and of course the fact that
Charlie Kirk's big concern is we were
relying on that court in order to try to
win in 2024 tells you everything you
need to know about who and what they
care about he's sang The Quiet part out
loud that Wisconsin result could end up
being really important as I've mentioned
before I supplement my diet with
vitamins every day I've tried different
methods none have been simpler or more
cost effective than just a daily scoop
of ag-1 from our sponsor athletic greens
with the one scoop I get the 75 high
quality vitamins and minerals from whole
food sources that I want I'm covered for
the day I'm not messing around with
different vitamin cap capsules and then
some have 200 and some have 180 so they
run out at different times and it's a
mess it's a mess this is simple The
Taste is good you can put it in water
juice or shakes each serving is under
three bucks a day compare that to what
all of the individual supplements would
cost you and it just makes sense
simplify your life by starting the day
with a scoop of 75 high quality
nutrients when you go to
athleticgreens.com Pacman you'll get a
free year supply of vitamin D I've
talked about vitamin D before and five
free travel packs of ag1 the link is
down below